JACKIE: Please welcome to Google
New York, Chris Stang
and Andrew Steinthal, aka
Immaculate Infatuation.
[APPLAUSE]
JACKIE: Hi.
CHRIS STANG: Hi.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Hi.
JACKIE: Again.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Thanks
for having us.
JACKIE: Thanks for joining us.
CHRIS STANG:It took us like two
months to write that bio.
JACKIE: And it is a great bio.
CHRIS STANG: Sounds really
good, though.
JACKIE: It really does.
CHRIS STANG: Especially coming
out of your mouth.
JACKIE: Well, thanks.
I've rehearsed it 10
times morning.
CHRIS STANG: Oh, I'm sure.
JACKIE: I'm very excited.
So these guys have a great
presentation to share and some
basic background about who they
are and about the website
and how it grew.
So I'm going to turn
it over to them.
And then we'll do
some Q&A after.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Let's not get
carried away with great
presentation.
It's actually a PowerPoint.
CHRIS STANG: No, we should
actually build it up to be.
JACKIE: I've seen
these photos.
CHRIS STANG: It's
very technical.
JACKIE: They are.
They are very tech savvy,
and their photos are--
CHRIS STANG: There's an
algorithm involved.
JACKIE: Yes.
CHRIS STANG: You'll
be impressed.
Hi, I'm Chris.
This is Andrew.
Thank you for having us.
This is all very surreal when
we do these things.
Because you have to understand
that we still sit behind a
computer and write these
restaurant reviews every night
and forget that people
actually read them.
So it's nice to be here.
This is cool.
JACKIE: This is great.
CHRIS STANG: So I guess the
presentations we've done, when
we've done this, and just
started off with us talking
about how we started the
website, why we started the
website, how it grew, where it
is now, and then eventually,
where we think we can
take it and what we
want to do with it.
And then we'll get into that
awesome, very impressive,
presentation.
JACKIE: Amazing pictures.
CHRIS STANG: So Andrew and
I met about 10 years ago.
We were both at our respective
universities--
Colorado State for
me, which is--
JACKIE: My alma mater--
CHRIS STANG: Which is Jackie's
alumnus, too.
And then Andrew was at Ithaca.
And we are both working in
college radio, so we ended up
at the CMJ music convention,
I guess it was
like the year 2000.
And it was right during the time
when Carson Daly was in
the heat of it.
He was the baddest dude
on television.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: TRL was hot.
CHRIS STANG: TRL was really,
really, really hot.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Remember
that time?
Those were crazy times.
JACKIE: It was fun.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Music
was a huge deal then.
JACKIE: I know.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: It was
not like it was today.
Not that music's
not a big deal.
But it was the marquee event.
It was Backstreet Boys and 'N
Sync and Britney, and things
were happening.
CHRIS STANG: We miss
those days.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Limp Bizkit.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Oh yeah.
CHRIS STANG: So we had
a mutual friend
that ran a music company.
And he had somehow weaseled his
way into getting passes to
go to the TRL studio.
And we each, independently,
got a phone call that was
like, dude come down
to the TRL studio.
And absolutely we were going.
So we ended up meeting each
other as we were sitting in
line to go into the studio.
And I think Destiny's Child
was on that day.
JACKIE: Amusing.
CHRIS STANG: And they put us
right in that corner window
right behind Carson.
So we were sitting next
to each other.
It was like, oh what's
up dude?
And they went through one
segment and Carson
was doing his thing.
And basically walked up to us
when the commercial break came
on, and they were like,
you guys gotta move.
We were like, what?
What are you talking about?
They were like, you're
not clapping enough.
And so basically, they pretty
much subbed in two 14-year-old
girls that would lose their
mind every time he said
Beyonce, or whatever else.
JACKIE: Destiny's Child,
Limp Bizkit.
CHRIS STANG: And we
got relegated to
the crowd off camera.
But we met and got along, and
hit it off, and kept in touch
until we graduated, and then
ended up both in New York City
after school, with a mind set
on the music business.
We were convinced that we could
take over the world.
JACKIE: And clearly, you are.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: That's not--
CHRIS STANG: Combine our
talents, and get into some
sort of music career Voltron.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Yeah, so we
came up together in the music
business and always had
this idea that we
wanted to do something.
We really believed that we could
do something together.
We weren't exactly sure what
it was going to be.
But we knew we could
do something.
And we had lots of ideas
along the way.
Most of them never
materialized.
We had a t-shirt company that
made one t-shirt once.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS STANG: We didn't
even sell it.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: No.
I have it.
JACKIE: Why didn't
you wear it?
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
It didn't fit.
It was terrible.
CHRIS STANG: It was bad.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Anyway.
CHRIS STANG: It was
a really deep V.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
No, it wasn't.
No.
It was a crew neck, dude.
CHRIS STANG: All right.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: So we
had a couple ideas.
We started.
We worked in the music business,
so I do publicity
and Chris does marketing
at Atlantic records.
And I work at Warner
Brothers records.
And we became the guys in the
office that knew the city
really well, were always out,
and people would come to for
recommendations, whether it was
a bar, or restaurant, or
whatever, because we were going
to all these shows.
We had bands to entertain, bands
to take out to dinner.
So there was a lot of decisions
to be made.
And we would likely be the ones
to make those decisions
and plan a fun night
around a show or
with a band, or whatever.
So we wound up going to tons
of dinners, eating a lot of
meals, going to a
lot of shows.
And just became this thing where
people would come to us
with all these things.
We were like, damn.
If we can recommend places for
our friends in the office, and
then our regular friends outside
of the office, whether
it's like our friend banker
dudes from JP Morgan, or
whoever, being like, yo dude I
got a date, where should I
take her, whatever, come through
for them-- if we were
becoming these guys, we were
like, maybe we can make
something of that.
Because there wasn't really
anybody talking our language
about restaurant reviews
and restaurants.
CHRIS STANG: I think
that's the key.
We realized as our friends would
call us and be like,
where am I taking my mom
for dinner tonight?
It just occurred to us that they
were calling us because
there wasn't a good resource for
them to find it otherwise.
So the "New York Times" wasn't
necessarily filling
that void for them.
Yelp was probably too much--
there's too much noise there.
And so I think friends of ours
were finding it difficult to
find a place to turn to find a
good way to sort out from all
the restaurants in New York City
where to go specifically
for certain things.
JACKIE: And for the trusted--
they know you guys.
They trust you guys.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
So then it just became, can we
do this on a larger scale and
serve that purpose
for other people?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: A lot of
places that do restaurant
reviews, it's very highbrow.
And for us, personally, a lot
of it's over our heads.
We are not food critics.
I mean, at this point, I guess
we are food critics.
But we're not experts in the
field of culinary brilliance.
We didn't study it.
We don't know the ins
and outs of it.
But we know New York City.
We know restaurants.
And we know how to read a
situation and whether
restaurant's good to take a girl
there, or good to just go
scope some hot dudes there, if
you're a female, good to go
with your parents, good
to go for whatever the
occasion may be.
And I think it's putting that
into context that people can
use on a daily basis that's
made it separate.
Because when we would go look
for restaurants in the past,
we'd go to "New York Magazine,"
because that was
probably a resource that we
used to go find things.
And we'd click, oh Chelsea
and Critics Pick.
But Critics Pick was really
one of the only search
functions that you could
actually pick to find
something, where you
might want to eat.
JACKIE: Yeah.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: So using that,
thinking about that, and
be like, OK, if we can expand
this and really make it
something that is useful on a
day to day basis, we could be
on to something that people
might find useful.
JACKIE: So how did
you expand it?
Did you start it as
a blog or website?
CHRIS STANG: I don't really
know what the
difference is anymore.
We just put up a website.
I guess it was chronological,
like we would
plug a review in.
And then we'd plug
another one in.
It would move it
down the list.
And we had tags that
you could sort by.
We called these things "Perfect
For" categories--
so perfect date night, perfect
for girls night
out, whatever it was.
And so we didn't really have
a conversation about it.
We just started writing
restaurant reviews.
We made up of format and then
put the "Perfect For"
categories on it, and then just
started plugging it into
the chronological, I
guess blog, format.
And then after probably six
months-- we knew from the
outset that we wanted to move
really fast and we want to
start cranking out restaurant
reviews so that it became a
useful database, quickly.
So a few, probably four or five
months in, we started
talking about how are we going
to make this searchable, and
make it something that you can
dive into, and add more than
one parameter to search by
and things like that.
So we really just
were winging it.
We're still just winging it.
We just put it up online.
And the funny thing was that
once we put the first few
reviews up and started
sending it around, it
just started spreading.
And we felt that reaction
almost immediately.
It's kind of funny going back
and looking at the emails we
still have from people.
They started coming in
within a couple weeks
of putting it up.
So that was really the
motivation to say, OK, let's
keep going.
Let's keep doing this, and let's
figure out a really grow
it and serve a purpose.
JACKIE: How many years
has it been?
CHRIS STANG: It will be
four years in April
that we put it up.
JACKIE: And many followers
or community?
How big is your community now?
CHRIS STANG: I think between
our app and the website, we
probably hit about 100,000
people a month.
JACKIE: That's great.
That's powerful.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
Look, it's been incredible.
I think we're still
overwhelmed by
the response to it.
And I think a big part of what
we realized early on too is
that we really wanted it to be
more than just a website.
We wanted to build a community
around it, because we were
getting such great, passionate
response, and people saying,
look you've become my go-to for
restaurant reviews, and I
love the way write.
And we kept hearing from people
that they felt like we
talked like they talked and that
we eat like they eat, and
that it was just relatable
for whatever reason.
So as we would discuss things,
we just decided, look, I think
we're doing it right.
We set out to serve a purpose
for people that didn't maybe
have a great resource
for these things.
And it occurred to us that
that's a community.
Those are people that, why
wouldn't they like to hang out
with each other?
And why wouldn't they want to
meet each other and be around
other like minded people?
So we've always, from pretty
early on, thought of this as
more than just a website.
How are we going to connect
the people that read the
website together and really
build a community around it?
JACKIE: Very cool.
So what kind of things are
you guys doing now?
I know Turkey Leg Ball,
which I went to,
which was a great event.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: That's
our one time of year
where we get married.
CHRIS STANG: It's the
Infatuation wedding.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: No, just
kidding, but not really.
It's the one time we get our
community together and just
throw a really good party.
We bring in interesting--
try and do something cool
on the food end.
Last year, we had Union Square
Events cater it, which is
Danny Meyer's catering
company.
And the whole thing
was turkey legs.
And it was lots of huge turkey
legs and girls eating massive
turkey legs.
And it was funny and very
photogenic, too.
Lots of good photos that
come along with eating
a big turkey league.
But get a lot of really good
booth sponsors, and have some
music, and just have not a
non-stuffy food party, because
a lot of these food parties are
white tablecloths, $200 a
ticket, really high scale.
And we want to just
go have fun.
But you can do that with
food, as well.
This year we brought in a
restaurant from Austin--
Foreign and Domestic--
who we really love.
JACKIE: Amazing.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: We did our
South by Southwest dinner
there last year, and we
were just blown away.
And the chefs there, Ned and
Joby, are a husband wife team
that are just awesome.
And we wanted to bring them to
New York for a night and
attempt to feed 500 people,
which they did.
And it was great.
And we had some great
booth sponsors--
Macallen and Brugal Rum and
wines from Domain Select.
And it was just cool.
It was a fun time.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah, that's
a good example, too.
I think the party--
it's funny how that developed
for us too.
We just, about a year in, were
getting such great response
from people that reached
out to us.
We thought, all right,
could we get these
people in a room together?
And the first year we did it.
And it was great.
It sold out really fast.
And it was a lot of fun.
So we decided that that was
going to be something we used
as a way to community
build again.
And we want to do more of it.
It's really, really, really
difficult to put on a
successful event.
And it pretty much kills
both of us every year.
But it's fun.
We find that the group that
comes out is ready to have fun
and ready to eat.
Our chefs from this year,
we had so much food.
And they came up to us at the
end and they were like, I
don't know who these people
are, but they eat, man.
And they were blown away by the
amount of consumption that
was happening on all levels
at the party.
But it's fun.
It's definitely fun.
So that's something
we want to grow.
And I think--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: It's
interesting to see, too,
because the people are starting
to know each other.
The people who communicate
with us online, like on
Twitter, and on Instagram and
stuff, they're starting to
communicate with each
other a little bit.
And then they go
to the events.
And they're starting to
know who they are.
And there are definitely some
people we've picked out from
the crowd that we really like
think are hysterical or think
are entertaining and are just
blowing their spots up online,
and making a big
deal out of it.
And it's really interesting just
to see it go from the web
and then go into real life,
and these people actually
talking and becoming friends and
connecting with each other
and feeling like they're a part
of something that's not
just a website.
JACKIE: Yeah.
It's really interesting.
Something that I'm really
fascinated by is the idea of
taking something that starts on
the web, bringing it into
an actual experience, and then
also bringing it back to the
web, and how that grows.
And I think one of the reasons,
and the things that I
love about your site and about
you guys, is you do that.
You do that really well, whether
or not you're giving
yourselves enough
credit for it.
But it's fun, and it's
entertaining. and
it's great to watch.
It's great reading, because I
feel like when I read your
website, and your reviews, I
feel like it's how you talk.
It's not like I'm reading
something very formal.
One of them you right something
about ectoplasm from
Ghostbusters.
And it's very entertaining.
And it's very fun and
user friendly.
CHRIS STANG: See, I think we've
just always tried to
think in terms of what we like
and what people we know like.
And really, you hit
it on the head.
We're not writers, so we just
write like we talk, and try
and inject humor into it.
I think we always also wanted to
be one of those sites that
people visit every day.
I think you have a handful
of websites that you have
bookmarked and that
you hit every day.
And we always wanted
to be one of those.
So I think more than anything,
we just wanted to be part of
people's lives, more than just
a website, something that
people feel like they're part of
and rally around and enjoy
interacting with,
and all that.
So it's been fun.
Look, we talk a lot about where
we're going to go with
it and how it grows.
And I think that's probably the
challenge that's been the
most difficult for us
here, at this point.
You brought up a good point.
We're talking about a few
different parts of this, one
of which is we can grow a
lot in New York City.
So we're obviously
trying to do.
And we want to be much bigger
than we are here.
But then we also start talking
about national expansion and
how to do that.
And the challenge is how do we
find people that are like us
to start it in other cities and
to write in other cities.
Because I'm not so sure you can
just go grab a writer and
put them on the case of writing
restaurant reviews for
another city and have it feel
the same way that it feels for
us in New York.
I think it's very key to have
just a common, average person
that loves to eat out, maybe
that has a good sense for
dropping an f-bomb at the
perfect time in a restaurant
review or something.
But I don't think we can just go
hire people that write for
other websites or that
write about food.
I think that's the thing that
we're trying to figure out.
It's almost like on the music
side, it's like A&Ring a band.
You've got to go find great
people in other
cities that can do it.
And then grow it.
So that's the place we're in
now is we're basically
starting a process that over the
next year we'll start to
expand in other cities.
And we'll show couple.
I'm sure most of you that are
familiar with the site have
seen the app, and some of the
other stuff that we do.
But obviously product
development, and on the mobile
side is super important to us.
So those are some of the things
that we're going to
focus on as we move forward.
But it's funny.
As much as this has been us just
winging it based on gut
instincts for things and what
we think people will like,
when you start to get into that
place of crossing over
into how do we grow this and do
it well and do it smart so
that it works in other
places, it's tricky.
JACKIE: Very.
Can we take a look at the app?
CHRIS STANG: Yeah, sure.
JACKIE: I'm actually curious
for everybody
to take a look at.
But also, is the focus going
to be on growing mobile?
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
It's funny, the app was
one of those things
that we talked about.
We couldn't understand why no
one had done an app that was
just really simple, like
I'm standing here,
what's around me?
Yelp obviously has
that function.
You can search a Yelp thing and
then flip it over and see
the locations around
you on a map.
But it's not curated, right?
And I think that's maybe one
thing we haven't talked about
that's key for us is the curated
voice seems to be
something that people
really want
online in a lot of topics.
So there's so much user
generated content.
Everybody has an opinion.
So many people in the tech world
now are coming up with
apps and things like that that
aggregate everyone's opinion
and try and weight it based on
whatever they decide to weight
it on, so that there's more
credible people, I guess, in
your feed versus less
credible people.
But for us, we just
feel like the
one-way opinion is helpful.
Whether or not you agree with
us, that's up to you.
But at least you know
where we stand, and
it's a one-way opinion.
Purposely we don't have
commenting on the reviews for
that reason.
Because we don't want you to
read our restaurant review and
see our opinion and then have
somebody right under it just
be like, yeah right, or
I hate this place.
Because even if it's only a
little bit, it undermines the
validity of the opinion,
I think.
JACKIE: Yeah, the
curated aspect.
CHRIS STANG: So to go back, the
reason I brought that up
is the mobile thing.
We just felt like, why
doesn't "New York
Magazine" have this app?
Or why hasn't somebody
else done this?
And we kept hearing from people
in our community that
just really wanted the ability
to take the website on the
road and when they're out.
I'm sure we've all been there,
where you're standing around
and you're like, where
am I going tonight?
Or you walk into a restaurant
and the wait's too long, and
you're trying to think
of a backup plan.
So really the biggest thing with
the app, the first and
most important function was the
nearby function, which is
just basically very simple
geo-aware map.
And it shows you our
reviews around you.
JACKIE: Can we take
a look at that?
CHRIS STANG: Yeah, sure.
JACKIE: That'd be great.
CHRIS STANG: We'll show you.
It's very, very technical
and impressive.
JACKIE: But that's one of the
things that's great about is
that it is very straightforward.
But it is very user friendly.
And I think the thing that's
really interesting is that
it's your voice.
You guys have a very
strong voice.
But it's very friendly and--
CHRIS STANG: Thank you.
JACKIE: Very straightforward.
CHRIS STANG: Can you
guys see this?
No?
JACKIE: Can you guys zoom
in at all on that?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: It's not
optimized for iPad.
CHRIS STANG: No, but--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Is it iPhone only?
CHRIS STANG: Yes, right now.
Is this working at all?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I mean if
Google wants to pay for our
Android app to be developed,
we are--
CHRIS STANG: By the
way, no problem.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
We'd be down.
CHRIS STANG: Does that
work at all?
Can you see it?
So this is the nearby
function.
It's pretty simple.
You'll see these little pens
that each have our reviews.
Is that better?
There we go.
That's totally on Google now.
It's on Android.
So the way the app works is you
open it up, and the first
thing you see is our first 12
reviews, just chronologically,
that we've written, and then a
little intro to the review.
And you can go deeper in and
read the whole review from the
home screen.
And we obviously knew that
we had to have all the
information in there, whether
it's the restaurant
information, the ability to
share it, so on and so forth.
But like I said, the
nearby thing is as
simple as it sounds.
It's just, basically,
I'm standing there.
And here's the restaurant
around me.
And you can basically get a
little summary of what it is
before you dive in.
Obviously you can basically
search it and stack the
filters so that you deduce it
down to a certain review based
on location, perfect
for, cuisine.
And actually, it started out,
because of our music business
background, part of the thing we
started with was we started
doing reviews, restaurants
that were
close to music venues.
Because that was something that,
at least for the two of
us, was really useful.
Because we were going to a show
and we needed to know
where we were eating
before that show.
So we expanded that out now to
landmarks and things like that
people that are in town from
other places might use.
And so you can basically just
stack a bunch of filters up
and hopefully find a couple of
options that are useful.
And then the last one that came
towards the end of our
development phase was
the hit list.
And basically the hit list for
us was just an answer to all
of our friends, including us,
that would start a note in
their iPhone or on the
BlackBerry or whatever, or
even an email draft, and
list restaurants.
Because I know tons of
people still do that.
Somebody will tell you
about a restaurant.
You open up an email draft or
something, and you write the
restaurant name down.
Then you lose your BlackBerry
or something.
So the way that we decided to
deal with this was you go in
and basically you
read a review.
And if you decide you want hit
the place, you just add to
your hit list.
And then it'll be in there.
And then it turns the
pins red on the map.
So hopefully, when you're
seeing a whole bunch of
different restaurants, you'll
see a couple red pins and
realize that those are hit
list restaurants that
you want to go to.
JACKIE: Very nice.
CHRIS STANG: And so
that's the app.
It's pretty much the same.
We've basically had
a few versions.
We added the social sharing
to it not that long ago.
But it's pretty much the same
as it was when it started.
It was a guy that now runs
product development for us,
who I used to work with.
It was the first app
he ever built--
he and his friend.
So we got really lucky.
They did a great job with it.
We feel like it's really
simple and easy to use.
And it's done really
well for us.
It's been a really big
part of our growth.
And I think it's been probably
the most important thing we've
done since we started
the site.
JACKIE: Nice.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you only feature
places that you recommend?
Or perhaps would a pin
show up and be like--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: No, the pin's
got everything on it.
In the app, you can get any
review that we've done,
whether it's a good
or bad review.
Because you might like
that restaurant.
You might disagree with us.
I'm not looking to take bad
reviews out of the app.
CHRIS STANG: We also want
you to make sure--
places we don't like--
the whole point is that you're
not going to go there and have
a bad experience.
We're trying to keep you from
wasting money on a terrible
restaurant.
And obviously, that's subjective
to some extent.
But that's what this is for.
It's to sort out the
good from the bad.
And we have an opinion on it.
So everything on the site is
in here and we definitely
review restaurants negatively.
And that's also something that
we get a lot of feedback about
is we're just really honest.
We're very careful not
to have ties into
the restaurant community.
We're not friends with chefs.
We don't tell people we're
coming into restaurants.
We don't go to restaurant
industry events.
So we try to stay very far away
from it, because we want
to remain outsiders.
And it also allows us to just
be completely unbridled and
honest if we don't
like a place.
And that way we're still--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: We might get
killed one day, though.
There are a couple of people out
there that definitely want
to destroy us.
CHRIS STANG: That's true.
AUDIENCE: Are you able
to share the hit
list with your friends?
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
Next version.
It's coming.
Working on that, because that's
important, I think,
being able to take the hit list
and not even just share
it with your friends on your
iPhone or whatever, but
online, on Facebook, on your
blog, on Twitter, wherever you
want to share it.
I think that's a big part of
building this community up.
We've started to have
this community.
And now we want to engage
the community.
We don't want to
have comments.
But we want people to be able to
use Immaculate Infatuation,
make it their own, and build
upon that, really get people
to interact with the site and
use it for something that
they'll enjoy using, and be
able to share with their
friends, and can quantify a
lot of this stuff better.
And we're working on
that for soon.
CHRIS STANG: I think that
goes back to what
you were saying too.
It's that take it from online
to offline, and then back
online again.
That's the next stage for us,
is really using the mobile
part of this to connect
everybody.
So that if you're using the app,
you can, like you were
saying, share the hit list.
But you can maybe also find
out where somebody's going
tonight and build in a bunch of
information into the mobile
side of it, too.
So that's definitely a big
part of it for us.
AUDIENCE: How are you keeping
the reviews up to date?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Stay up until
2:00 AM every night
writing restaurant reviews.
CHRIS STANG: Do you mean,
like, older reviews?
Yeah.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: That's
a problem.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS STANG: We've done a
good handful of updates.
I mean, we've definitely
realized from the earlier
stuff that we've done that there
are places we definitely
need to go back to
and reassess.
And we try to.
But for New York City, if
there's a restaurant that's
still around, and it's been
there for four years, there's
a pretty good chance it hasn't
changed all that much.
The menu stuff probably
changes.
But like Freeman's Alley
was one of the
first places we reviewed.
We actually updated that review
since we started.
But those places don't
change all that much.
But that's something we're going
to start probably doing
more of, especially now
that we've been
around for four years.
It wasn't such a big deal up
until pretty recently.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: And you go
back and read our old reviews.
And we're just like, wow,
these are terrible.
[LAUGHTER]
JACKIE: So I'm really curious
to see this presentation.
CHRIS STANG: So yeah,
we'll get in, I
guess, to more questions.
But we have a Frequently Asked
Questions presentation.
JACKIE: It could answer some of
the questions that could be
in the room.
CHRIS STANG: So this might
answer some of the ones you
have already.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: OK,
don't judge me.
It's not my computer.
There's cats in the
background.
It's my wife's computer.
Those aren't my cats.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Not that
cat people are horrible.
But I just would rather be
qualified as a dog person than
a cat person.
I have problems with this
whole cat thing.
Anyway, OK.
Sorry.
CHRIS STANG: We should probably
put that into the
FAQs presentation
for next time.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: How
did you guys meet?
We already went over that.
But this is us at the Grammys,
the first year we ever met.
And we legitimately wore that
and thought we were awesome.
CHRIS STANG: Let's clarify
something, though.
We weren't invited
to the Grammys.
We bought tickets.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: No, we
didn't buy tickets.
We got free tickets.
CHRIS STANG: We got tickets.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
We were excited.
It was, like, the
best day ever.
CHRIS STANG: Right, but
let's just be clear.
We were not invited because we
were some sort of luminaries
from the music business.
We were two guys in the nose
bleeds at Madison Square
Gardens in tuxes
that we rented.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: And I wore
a Knicks headband.
CHRIS STANG: And a
Knicks headband.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: The Patrick
Ewing retirement
game was that week.
It was important.
And real puffy here.
CHRIS STANG: And that tuxedo's
three sizes too large.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: OK, next.
Where did the name come from?
So that is the original
Immaculate Infatuation.
That is a fake British rock band
that we dressed up as--
me and my friends-- for
Halloween one night in college
up at Ithaca, and put on British
accents and called
ourselves Immaculate
Infatuation.
And it just was a name that
always stuck with me.
And I just liked it.
And I guess the world was in
need of a food blog you
couldn't pronounce the name of,
and Immaculate Infatuation
was born, because we didn't want
to be something cheesy.
The other thing we were thinking
of was Eats Beat,
because it was food and music.
But that was real lame.
So we decided to go with
Immaculate Infatuation instead.
CHRIS STANG: This is a
very astute use of
clip art, by the way.
It took me hours to do this.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: The
answer is what?
Three days a week?
Four days a week?
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: As
much as possible?
CHRIS STANG: Yep.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
But it's tricky.
No.
CHRIS STANG: Especially
not this guy.
I hope that guy doesn't
work at Google.
So yeah, like I said
before, that's sort
of a cardinal rule.
We don't tell people we're
coming ahead of time.
We don't accept offers to
be guests of chefs or
restaurants.
We just go in and eat, just
like anybody else would.
It's really important to us to
have the same experience that
anybody going into the
restaurant would normally.
So the answer to this is because
we run like we're
getting chased.
Basically, the both of us run
probably 12 miles a week just
to work off the pork buns
and bone marrow that
goes into our system.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Now I'm
really into SoulCycle.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah he's
into SoulCycle.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I'm fine
with admitting that.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS STANG: Are you
guys dating?
This comes up less now that
Andrew wears a wedding ring.
But we dealt with questions
like that a lot.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: The
answer is no.
But we have probably one of
the gayer straight male
relationships that exist.
CHRIS STANG: That's true.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: And we are
definitely in a serious
relationship.
CHRIS STANG: Exhibit A.
Photos like that.
Go back.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Whoops.
I don't know how to go back.
Previous.
CHRIS STANG: There you go.
Keep going.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS STANG: So yeah, I
think Andrew touched
on it a little bit.
We write pretty much entirely
late at night.
I think we both are up until
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning
many nights, finishing
reviews.
And then the weekends are
obviously full of activities
that are based around Immaculate
Infatuation.
But I'm sure lots of people
here have experienced it.
It's like you have a
moonlight hour job.
It's one of those things where
if you're passionate and you
love it, it doesn't really
seem like work.
But you realize that you're
probably doing very bad things
to your body by not sleeping
and only eating restaurant
food all the time.
It's great that we get reached
out to all the time.
This is even more relevant now,
because we are looking
for people to do some writing
for us in other places.
But it's funny.
The food blogger thing, there
seems to be an interesting
perception around that word.
And not that we're
adverse to it.
But it's funny.
I guess the reason that image
is there is we try not to be
like food bloggers in
the sense that--
I think there's a bit of a--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Stigma?
CHRIS STANG: No, not a stigma.
It's almost like the
word foodie.
People use it to separate
themselves from other people.
And it's like, wait a minute,
you like food?
No kidding.
I can't believe it.
JACKIE: I like food, too.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
So yeah, I think we're obviously
on the lookout just
for people like us that love
to eat and aren't food
bloggers already, and aren't
writers already, but also have
similar interests.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Yeah.
CHRIS STANG: So that's it.
I hope you like the clip art.
JACKIE: Clip art was amazing.
So before we open it up to more
questions, we have some
questions put together.
And it's pretty basic,
straightforward.
But something we like
to do here is
some speed round questions.
CHRIS STANG: Ready.
JACKIE: So I have a couple
different versions.
CHRIS STANG: Do we
have to go fast?
JACKIE: Yes, very.
So the first round is speed
round, Immaculate style.
So in New York, the best place
for action at the bar?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Spotted Pig.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Never
lets you down.
Always action, so much action.
You just got to be prepared
for the action.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JACKIE: Chronic brunch?
CHRIS STANG: Oh, that's
a good one.
Chronic brunch--
Cafe Habana, probably.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Cafe Habana.
CHRIS STANG: It's cheap.
It's awesome.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Clinton
Street Bakery.
I mean, Clinton Street Bakery,
the lines are impossible.
But if you go there
on a weekday, the
pancakes are just absurd.
JACKIE: They are amazing.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
They're amazing.
Prune, also, for just straight
brunch is phenomenal.
JACKIE: Dinner with
the parents?
CHRIS STANG: Either Maialeno,
Maraya, depending on who your
parents are.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS STANG: Yeah, Babbo's
great, some of those classic
restaurants.
I love Blue Ribbon Brasserie,
which is the original Blue
Ribbon, not the sushi place.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
Mas Farmhouse.
My mom loves that place.
It's a good spot.
JACKIE: Moms love it.
Mom's approve.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Five
Points, too.
That's a great parents place.
Because that's not as fancy
as all the other
ones, but really good.
For the parents, that's
really cool.
They go in there, and they're
like, wow, I'm having the most
awesome downtown New York
night right now.
CHRIS STANG: There's a tree
inside the restaurant.
That's always impressive.
JACKIE: And what about
impressing out-of-towners?
CHRIS STANG: The Momofuku's
are always good for that.
Same thing with Ippudo, just
because it's such an anomaly.
I love that place.
And it's just crazy.
Those places are great.
I still love the Blue Ribbon
Brasserie one for that, too,
because it's open until
4:00 in the morning.
So you can always blow people's
minds by having a
full on amazing dinner
at 2:00 AM.
JACKIE: That's good stuff.
So besides the cafeterias at
Google New York, where is the
favorite place for you guys
to eat right now--
locally or the US?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Locally?
Does Chelsea Market count?
Because you guys are really
lucky to have
that across the street.
We work in midtown.
And we got to deal with
Rock Center for
lunch, which is brutal.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Chelsea Market
is just like an oasis
of incredibleness.
We walk around there, and we're
like holy shit, what
would we do if we actually
worked here?
It would be great.
CHRIS STANG: I would say that
probably the best answer to
that question for us right now
is Austin, Texas as a whole.
JACKIE: Interesting.
CHRIS STANG: That
city is amazing.
There's so much great
food there.
And we go a lot just for
South by Southwest.
But it's also just becoming
a place we go just to eat.
Because there are incredible
restaurants down there of all
shapes and sizes, whether it's
barbecue or a place like
Foreign and Domestic,
who we brought for
our Turkey Leg Ball.
It's a great city altogether.
But the food, especially,
is amazing.
JACKIE: Awesome.
So being in music world, I need
to ask, if you could have
dinner with any musician,
who would it be and
where would you eat?
CHRIS STANG: Good question.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: That's
really good question.
CHRIS STANG: Jay-Z at Lucali.
That would be awesome.
JACKIE: That's amazing.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I would like
to join that dinner.
JACKIE: Can I join
that dinner?
CHRIS STANG: I think Lucali
might be closed forever.
But we'll figure out where Jay-Z
likes to go after that.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I'd go with
Thom Yorke somewhere.
But he'd be real weird.
I'm trying to think of what the
weirdest place you can go
and not speak to somebody is.
Because he probably wouldn't
speak at the dinner table.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW STEINTHAL: He'd probably
just like freak out
and whatever.
CHRIS STANG: That's
a good answer.
JACKIE: That's awesome.
OK, so the second set of
speed round questions.
This is Googly Style,
as we call it.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Googly Style.
Nice.
JACKIE: Googly Style.
So pick the best answer--
the best one--
that most suits you.
And we'll do Chris.
And then go right to Andrew.
So coffee or tea?
CHRIS STANG: Coffee.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Neither.
JACKIE: Ooh.
Brown liquor or clear liquor?
CHRIS STANG: Brown.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Brown.
JACKIE: Hip Hop, west
coast or east coast?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: It's not
even a thing anymore.
JACKIE: It is for me
and my generation.
CHRIS STANG: West coast.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: East coast.
JACKIE: 2Pac--
east coast?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Yes.
JACKIE: 2Pac hologram--
resurrection or lawsuit?
CHRIS STANG: I'm going
to go with lawsuit.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I'm going
definite resurrection.
It was awesome.
JACKIE: LEGOs or Muppets?
CHRIS STANG: Muppets, 100%.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: LEGOs.
JACKIE: Kicks, Nike
or Converse?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: It's
the same thing.
CHRIS STANG: Converse.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: No.
No, but I'm saying--
JACKIE: Yeah, but totally
different styles.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Absolutely,
but--
CHRIS STANG: You're not
doing this right.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: OK, sorry.
JACKIE: I'm going to
say that you--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Nike
all the way.
Thank you, Nike.
I love my sneakers.
JACKIE: Dark chocolate
or milk chocolate?
CHRIS STANG: Dark.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Milk.
JACKIE: They are really
the perfect pair.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
JACKIE: Last question.
You're totally housed.
It's 2 o'clock in the morning.
Pizza or burger?
CHRIS STANG: Burger.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Really?
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Joe's Pizza.
Final answer.
JACKIE: So if anybody else
has any questions.
I know we did a little bit
before, but you guys are
welcome to go to the mics.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Or just
raise your hands.
JACKIE: Or just raise
your hands, and
we'll repeat the question.
CHRIS STANG: I want to do this
like a presidential debate,
where we face off.
Sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask about
turning this into a
business, perhaps where you
could get rid of your day job.
You don't have to stay
up until 3:00 AM.
Is that where you want
to take this?
JACKIE: So just to repeat for
people on VC and recording,
she's asking growing the
business, staying up now until
3:00 AM, is it something that
eventually you want this to be
your primary?
CHRIS STANG: Yeah, we're lucky
in the sense that our day jobs
are dream jobs for us.
It's not so much the situation
where we're sitting, chained
to some desk, where we feel
like, God, if we could only
get out and do this thing we're
passionate about full time.
Clearly though, we
would love to.
It's something we are really
passionate about.
And we're ambitious.
I think we have lofty
goals for it.
So just like anything on the
internet, the monetization
part of it is tricky.
And it's also tricky to do
it right and do it well.
So that's something we're
figuring out as we go.
And I think we have some pretty
good ideas in terms of
what we can do.
But also we're just trying not
to speed into anything,
because I think that's when
you make mistakes.
So I think it's that
if you build it,
they will come mentality.
We can just do something that's
really great and build
a community around it, then the
rest of it will hopefully
come together.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: The one
thing we can definitely
control is the content.
If we continue to focus on the
content and make things that
people want and continue to
build this thing, I think
hopefully we'll figure
it out along the way.
Do we have a master plan as to
how we're going to make a ton
of money on this and be
able to whatever?
No.
But we have ideas as to
what we want to do.
And we think we can
figure it out.
So getting there.
JACKIE: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: What is the best
burger you've tried?
JACKIE: What is the best
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Every burger's
the best burger.
CHRIS STANG: I love
the one at--
there's a place called The
Burger Joint in the Parker
Meridien Hotel here.
JACKIE: It's good.
CHRIS STANG: And it's
really, really good.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: There's
different kinds.
One burger, there's the
fast food burger type.
There's the mid burger--
JACKIE: What's your
go-to burger?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: The
restaurant burger.
AUDIENCE: There's also
the Hopdoddy's
burgers in Austin, Texas.
CHRIS STANG: They're great.
That place is amazing--
Hopdoddy's in Austin.
It's another one.
Austin is so loaded with places
that that place doesn't
even make a lot of people's
lists of great Austin
restaurants.
But yeah, I love it.
It's really good.
And they're really creative.
It's certainly not all just
your traditional burgers.
They do all kinds
of different--
I think there's an
ostrich burger
on the menu or something.
But yeah, it's great.
Love it.
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
you don't or won't eat?
JACKIE: The question is, is
there anything that you won't
or don't eat?
CHRIS STANG: I'm pretty much
an equal opportunity eater.
There's not much of my list.
I don't think there's really
anything I won't eat.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I'm
really picky.
Compared to him, there's a lot
of things I won't eat.
Like mushrooms, I'm
petrified of.
Indian food scares the
shit out of me.
[LAUGHTER]
JACKIE: Indian food?
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
Yeah, olives.
I don't understand how
people eat olives.
It's disgusting.
They're disgusting.
JACKIE: So this is
interesting.
So you guys go into a restaurant
and you're like,
I'll have the mushroom and
olive pizza, without the
mushrooms and olives.
And he's like, I'll have the
pizza with the brain and the
tripe on it.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Right.
CHRIS STANG: But it's funny,
because I think that's also
part of what helps us remain
relatable is not everybody
that eats at restaurants is
Frank Bruni or Anthony
Bourdain and willing
to take down tripe.
So I think I'm certainly
more adventurous.
Andrew's a bit more picky.
But that's what people are
like, aren't they?
Everybody has a friend or a
boyfriend or girlfriend that
doesn't eat all the same
stuff they do.
JACKIE: Nice.
AUDIENCE: How many times do you
visit a restaurant before
writing a review?
JACKIE: The question is how
many times do you visit a
restaurant before you
write a review?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: It depends.
We can go once.
We could go four times.
If we go and have an experience
with a bunch people
that we really feel like we've
tasted the menu, and we feel
like we get the vibe, and we
know what the place is about,
we'll weigh in.
But a lot of times, it'll be
two times or three times,
where we just want to make sure
that we didn't just go
and have a fluke of a meal, or
whatever, just had a couple
dishes and then weigh
in on a place.
You want to give a place
a fair shake.
You want to get an idea of what
they're all about, what
their serving is, what the
crowd is, and all that.
So sometimes you can do
that in one time.
Sometimes it takes a minute.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah, but at the
same time, most restaurants
don't get that luxury from
normal people that just walk
into a restaurant.
If a place bums you out the
first time, there's no chance
you're going back.
And so it's something
we try and balance.
Yeah, maybe they're having
an off night.
But consistency is a huge part
of a great restaurant.
So it definitely depends.
But we're not afraid to go
into a place, have a bad
experience once, and write
about it being a bad
experience.
Because that's what happens.
JACKIE: Yeah.
In the front?
AUDIENCE: Are you specifically
looking for more off the
beaten path kind of
places that are
maybe less well known?
Or are you just as likely to
go to a super popular,
well-known place?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Try
and mix it up.
We love to try and unearth
some local finds.
We rely pretty heavily
on our community to
unearth those for us.
People email us all the time
and get after us on Twitter
and Facebook and stuff.
And they come at us with
recommendations.
And the places that we've never
heard of, we love to go
find a place.
Like, You were talking about
Post Office in Williamsburg.
It's a place that nobody's
really written about that
much, but it's incredible.
It's easily one of our favorite
places in the city.
It's just a brown liquor joint
that's got oysters and grilled
cheese and pulled
pork sandwiches.
But it's perfect.
It's exactly the kind of
place that we love.
And the food's awesome.
But nobody's really written
about it, really.
CHRIS STANG: It's funny, too,
because that place we gave a
9.0, and nobody had written
about it at the time.
And those places give us a
really good opportunity to see
what we can do with
our community.
So if we really put a stamp on a
place like that that doesn't
have the "New York Times" or
"New York Magazine" or whoever
else writing about
it, it's great.
Because we actually see
the impact of it.
We'll see people on social media
a couple days later,
saying that they're there.
And it's cool.
It's hard to have that
opportunity, because there's
so many other people writing
about all these other
restaurants.
It's hard to tell what
impact you have.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I think the
Post Office review was the
first time we ever actually
could see that we made a
difference somehow.
I think that after that review
that weekend we had so many
tweets from people at
the restaurant.
And that place is small.
That place maybe fits 40 people,
and we had 10, 11
different groups that
were there.
We were just like, holy shit,
there's people actually there,
because we gave a good review.
It's cool.
AUDIENCE: Aside from, obviously,
New York City and
then Austin, do you see any
cities that have really
exciting scenes?
JACKIE: So just besides New York
and Austin, do you know
of other cities, or what other
cities has really exciting
food scenes?
CHRIS STANG: It's funny.
Every city now, just because
restaurant culture's changed
so much in the last 15 years,
I feel like every city has
some little pocket of an amazing
restaurant community
growing up around it.
But there are certainly cities
that are just being overtaken.
Like Portland has a great
restaurant scene, Seattle
obviously does.
San Francisco is huge.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Nashville.
I want to go to Nashville.
CHRIS STANG: Nashville.
JACKIE: Nashville
is awesome food.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Nashville's
got some really
cool stuff going on.
CHRIS STANG: Charleston,
South Carolina.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Yeah.
CHRIS STANG: Even DC is starting
to have a cool
restaurant scene.
They've got some great
restaurants.
So those are probably the
top of the list places.
Chicago, obviously, has
tons of restaurants.
I left that one out.
But those are probably the top
of the list in terms of at
least places we put
on our map of--
JACKIE: And L.A.
CHRIS STANG: You know,
L.A.s funny.
L.A.s great, but I've spent a
lot of time there, for me the
food that really is memorable
in L.A. is the ethnic food.
Whether it's the Korean food or
Little Tokyo downtown, to
go to L.A. and go to the
restaurants that are New York
style restaurants, there's very
few that live up to it.
And every single one of them
has a valet in front, which
just seems really weird to me.
But it seems like in L.A.--
JACKIE: Because we
live in New York.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah.
Well, it's like the places that
really get talked about
in L.A. are more like
scene places.
But the great food, there's a
few places we love, but the
places in L.A. that really are
memorable, at least to me, are
the ethnic food.
JACKIE: Yeah, yeah.
There's some amazing
food out there.
AUDIENCE: How do you guys
decide where to go next?
JACKIE: The question is how do
they decide where to go next?
CHRIS STANG: We definitely
maintain our own hit lists.
It depends.
People will tell us
about places.
Social media's great for that.
Our community is great about
giving us a heads up on
restaurants we need to go to.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: There's
no real science to it.
We just like, oh shit
we need to go there.
Remember.
And oh, we haven't done a
Brooklyn review in a couple
weeks, we got to get
out to Brooklyn.
CHRIS STANG: We go to websites
like "Eater" are great for
that, because they definitely
keep a good list of openings.
And we also try not to just
depend on what's brand new.
So we'll try and sometimes
just go look around a
neighborhood and think, what are
these places that people
talk about in this neighborhood
and places that
we might have missed?
We ended up at a place called
Kajitsu in the East Village a
few weeks ago that has been
there for years and it's got a
Michelin Star, and somehow,
we just hadn't been there.
And it was great.
It's just funny.
New York's so unique in that
sense, that there's so many
restaurants that you really
can spend years.
We've written 600 restaurant
reviews, and we feel like
we're barely scratching
the surface here.
AUDIENCE: Do you usually
go with other people?
Or just the two of you?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: We
go-- we try and--
JACKIE: Do they go
by-- it's OK.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I can redo
the question, if you want.
JACKIE: Yeah, that'd be great.
CHRIS STANG: She's the
moderator, man.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Sorry.
JACKIE: Yeah, but Andrew,
take it away.
Go for it.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: In terms
of if we go together to
restaurants or if we go
with other people.
Did you like that?
That was good, right?
JACKIE: Excellent.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Right, cool.
JACKIE: Bright future here.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
We definitely--
CHRIS STANG: You're done.
We don't need you anymore.
JACKIE: I know.
Thanks guys.
I'm going to go grab some--
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Part of the
fun of this is getting a big
crew together and
going to eat.
That's part of the game.
We're constantly setting up
dinners, constantly going,
finding random people who share
our similar interests
and trying to go with
a bigger group.
Not a huge group, but a group
that's sizable enough where
you can taste a lot of things
and over-order, and all just
get into it.
We don't go together
all the time.
We definitely go
together a lot.
But we try and split it up so
that we each have different
things to write about.
AUDIENCE: Are you paying
for all of your
friends when you go?
CHRIS STANG: No,
definitely not.
JACKIE: Are you guys going
to repeat that?
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Are we paying
for all our friends
when we go to eat?
Absolutely not.
Hopefully someday we'll
be able to do that.
That would be lovely.
But as of right now, it's
expensive enough for us to go
pay for ourselves to eat.
CHRIS STANG: My AMEX card is
warm in my pocket, most of the
time, from overuse.
JACKIE: Great.
Well, this has been awesome.
I think it's just amazing to
see, just again, some ideas,
some passion, the web, good
friendship, love of food.
And you don't even really need
to know how to use PowerPoint
in order to access the web.
CHRIS STANG: Yeah,
clearly we--
JACKIE: And build a community
of 100,000.
ANDREW STEINTHAL: I barely
know how to use a Mac.
That's my problem.
JACKIE: Well, we have some great
solutions for that here.
ANDREW STEINTHAL:
I was on PCs.
JACKIE: So thanks, you guys,
so much for coming in.
And happy Friday, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW STEINTHAL: Cool,
thanks for having us.